we're going to begin this hour with a
story about what's behind those
real-life scammers that we're all
reading about you often see them
portrayed on the screen getting away
with lavish spending
always on someone else's dime movies and
shows like the tender swindler really
good and bad vegan offer a snapshot into
the record high number of imposter scams
sweeping the internet these days the
limited series inventing anna
highlighted a scam perpetrated in real
life by a woman in her twenties jerica
duncan has this look inside the minds of
con artists and how they charm
their often very smart victims
i'd like to
cash this check here the infamous
schemes basically just a big party
scheme manipulations this isn't
inspiring and lies we had a special
special connection have made their way
into movie theaters and on tv screens
for years what's you wearing you look
paw our fascination with con artists is
undeniable but for those who say they
have been scammed it can be devastating
she was someone i met through friends
rachel delosh williams was 28 years old
when she met anna sarokin in 2016. at
the time sirokan presented herself as a
young german heiress named anna delvey
who wanted to start an exclusive art
foundation in new york what was it about
her story that led you to believe that
she was very well off financially she
lived full time in a hotel
she was very cavalier with her spending
if she had been staying at the holiday
inn and said rachel
come have this continental breakfast
with me do you think you would have been
as apt to hang out with her
yeah she picked up the tabs sometimes in
the hotel but that wasn't why we were
friends what i was interested in was how
big her dreams were how ambitious she
she was
sirokan invited williams on a lavish
trip to morocco in 2017.
it was depicted in the fictional netflix
miniseries inventing anna williams says
the problem started when the posh hotel
demanded a working credit card these
managers came into the villa and said
to anna basically like you you guys
cannot leave the premise until there's a
functioning card on file and anna keeps
making promises about a wire or about
needing to call someone or waiting on
calls to be returned and
there was just no alternative after
putting her own cards down williams was
charged roughly 62 thousand dollars she
says sarokin promised to pay her back
but did not when williams eventually
went to the police she learned sirokan
had also targeted hotels and banks take
us inside the mind of a con artist
they don't have the same emotional
landscape right so they tend to have
more callous
emotion they tend to be less empathetic
so
reason that you and i don't lie very
often
is because it feels bad but for them it
doesn't psychologist jeff hancock
teaches communications at stanford one
of the reasons that they can be such
good liars is they can convince
themselves of a lot of things and this
kind of self-deceptions always scared me
because it's like how can somebody
know their line and believe themselves
in 2019 the fake heiress was convicted
of grand larceny and theft of services
williams allegations were part of the
criminal complaint against sarokin
she was released from prison in february
of 2021 but shortly after immigration
and customs officials arrested her for
overstaying her visa do you consider
yourself a con artist
absolutely not last month sirogen did an
interview from behind bars i never like
intended permanently
to permanently harm anybody what were
your thoughts when you listen to that
podcast
to hear her in her own words really
highlights that she
feels no remorse
she's really upset that she got caught i
think it's important when it you know to
understand
how
manipulation happens williams ended up
writing a book about her experience it's
published by gallery books part of
paramount which owns cbs would you want
to hear an apology from her at this
point does it matter i have no wish for
any engagement as far as zan is
concerned what do you want people to
know is this a
story of you gotta trust your gut you
pretty much nailed it if it's too good
to be true
it is
these con artists know what they're
doing they know how to manipulate people
and time pressure is one of them and
that's why i say when something doesn't
feel right slow down and if you can't
slow down then there's definitely
something wrong for cbs mornings jerica
duncan new york
anna sarokin was acquitted of stealing
from rachel williams williams told us
that siroccon did pay her back five
thousand dollars an attorney for
siroccon declined our request for an
interview so she got back the 5 000 guys
but it was over sixty two thousand
dollars that's a pretty big loss a huge
loss that's a pretty big loss i don't
like calling it the art of the con
because it sounds like it's charming
like it's just steve martin lifting you
out of the the drink tab i mean it's a
big financial burden i mean would you
rather get punched in the head lose
twenty dollars or be
conned by an artist out of sixty two
thousand and the other thing that i'm
fascinated by there's only psychology
i'm fascinated by the psychology of all
this and that's why i'm glad you recall
this piece because there are two lines
in her story that stuck out to me one is
when rachel says i was interested in how
big her dreams are and how ambitious she
was and the psychologist says con
artists tend to be less empathetic so
you are empathetic to their dreams to
their ambitions and they are not
empathetic to you so they capitalize and
that's how they will you in i like when
he said they know they're lying but they
believe it that's right i'm fascinated
by anybody who can do that